juan bien lo decía usted estamos en el
centro de votación más grande del país
donde 557.000 personas pueden votar en
este punto se abren las urnas para la
segunda vuelta presidencial donde los
candidatos el izquierdista gustavo petro
donde los colombianos deberán decidir
entre los dos candidatos el izquierdista
gustavo petro y su fórmula
vicepresidencial
francia márquez y el populista rodolfo
hernández y su fórmula vicepresidencial
mar en el castillo más de 39 millones de
personas están llamadas a las urnas que
se cerraran a las 4 de la tarde hacia
las 5 de la tarde
sabremos muy posiblemente quién va a ser
el próximo presidente de colombia el
abstencionismo en la primera vuelta fue
de alrededor del
45% una cifra que se espera que baje en
esta segunda vuelta presidencial este
45% fue la cifra más baja en los últimos
20 años según la registraduría nacional
de la nación la campaña estuvo marcada
por la polarización todo el fernández
llegó con un poco más de 6 millones de
votos o alrededor de 6 millones de votos
mejor superando a uno de los favoritos
que era el candidato del ex presidente
álvaro uribe federico gutiérrez que
quedó en tercer lugar el candidato
gustavo petro llegó con 8 millones y
medio de votos las encuestas de las
últimas semanas dan como un empate
técnico entre los dos candidatos por lo
que se prevén unos resultados muy
reñidos